look at the labor view on that shall we
we can talk to the party Shadow work and
pension secretary Jonathan ashware thank
you for being on the program today now
you're here with a different hat on of
course but you were shed of Health
secretary for a long time including
during the pandemic we did lots of
interviews on that
um so I do want to start off with the
NHS
um what state do you think the Health
Service is in as we approach winter
well it's in a quite desperate State
isn't it not only are seven million
people on the waiting list I think
around 400 000 people now are waiting
Beyond a year for treatment that's
that's four and a half Wembley stadiums
if you like and of course the typical
weight for somebody who needs treatment
has got has doubled from about seven
weeks to 14 weeks the problem of the NHS
is there's an increased Demand on the
NHS and there simply isn't the capacity
to meet that demand we are short of the
doctors the nurses the paramedics the
clip the clinical stuff that we need
which is why we're in the labor party
have said let's let's impose the or get
get rid of the non-dom tax status and
use as a proceeds from that to fund
extra doctors and nurses but we're
heading into a very difficult winter a
winter that will be miserable for
patients but also it impacts economic
growth we've now got two and a half
million people out of work because of
sickness costing us seven and a half
billion extra in sickness benefits
that's because many of those people
can't work because they're waiting for
mental health treatment although waiting
for an operation now one of the things I
want to do as a work and pension
secretary is use my years of expertise
in in health policy to reform the way in
which we provide support in job centers
and employment services to help those
who are sick uh get back into work
because there's evidence now if you
better integrate Employment Services
with health services with mental health
services you can actually support people
to return to work so the problems in the
health surface are having a direct
impact on people's ability to go back to
work and our overall economic
performance now the other thing that
Stephen Buckley said in our interview
earlier was that he wouldn't support he
doesn't recognize and wouldn't support
the front page of the Sunday time
suggestion that the government is
considering a closer link to the EU like
a Swiss style relationship so access to
the same Market which of course would
mean things like paying more into the
budget higher immigration and an
increased role for the European courts
of Justice
in principle would labor support
now what we've talked about is that we
need to make brexit work we obviously
need to deal with the problems in the
brexit deal and isn't it uh you know
ironic that we were told by Boris
Johnson's cabinet which of course Wishy
sunak was a leading member of as
Chancellor that we had this oven ready
deal the one of the best deals possible
and now it appears that conservatives
are briefing suggesting that the deal
isn't working out and they're and they
want to return to something which is
it's something more like Checkers so the
check of the old Checkers proposals look
what we need to do is we need to deal we
need to fix the problems in the deal we
need to look at Veterinary agreements so
we can be dealing with agricultural
products better we need to look at our
security Arrangements we do not need to
look at ways in which we can get more
frictionless trade because although the
volume of trade on the world stage has
improved our exports performance is
still disappointing so there are changes
that need to be made but it it's quite
something that conservances appear to be
briefing newspapers or government
sources appear to be beaten newspapers
suggesting that that own deal isn't
working out as they told as it would
okay um do you so you're saying though
that the uh the deal is not working I'm
just trying to work out exactly how far
labor would go to improve the situation
I mean would you be prepared for example
to look at access to the single Market
now we're not proposing returning to the
singles Mark the single Market or the
the Customs Union or anything like that
but we do want to negotiate a bespoke
deal for the United Kingdom and so that
so that our businesses can export so
that we can get those agreements on uh
agriculture so we can work together on
security issues but we're not we're not
no one we are not proposing that we just
simply adopt the Swiss proposal which
the government now are apparently
looking at but of course we need to fix
this deal of course we need to make
brexit work because this oven ready deal
that we were promised this great deal
has had has not worked out in the way in
which Rishi sunak and Boris Johnson tell
the British people it would do okay a
couple of other things that I'm Keen to
ask you about nurses are striking
demanding a 17 pay rise should they get
it
look what we very clearly said is that
of course nurses and other public sector
workers deserve a fair pay settlement
but these things need to be negotiated
through the proper way
now Steve Barkley I didn't hear his
interview I'm afraid because I've been
coming from another Studio but it's now
incumbent upon him to get all the Trade
union Representatives the
representatives of nurses doctors
paramedics and so on round a table to
avoid industrial action this winter
because we know the NHS is in a
desperate State and nobody wants to see
our energy staff we'll go on strike so
he had to get them I just want to come
in if I never out a deal I just want to
come in if I may because obviously you
know I'll ask Steve Barkley about what
he's doing on the NHS strikes but I just
want to get Labor's position you know
you talk about the independent process
but that independent process is not
going to give them a 17 pay rise is it
so do art by that do we assume that
labor also doesn't think that nurses
should get the pay rise that they want
well uh the health sector unions have
rejected the recommendations of the
independent pay review body processes so
it's now incumbent upon the health
secretary who don't forget in
legislation last year took more direct
control of the NHS that was one of the
things I was actually under Matt Hancock
and it's actually Javid but they took
more direct control of the NHS so
there's no hiding the book stops with
the health secretary if he wants to
avoid industrial action this winter he
has to get those trade unions in his
office on Monday morning to get an
agreement and Hammer out an agreement
now we've not got access to all the
facts and figures on in the NHS because
that's government information but I
would be if I but I am sure that if West
streeting was the health secretary he
would be getting the unions in for a
discussion and of course we never had
industrial action in the NHS okay under
a labor government two more quick
questions for you before I have to let
you go um according to the Observer
labor wants to polish the House of Lords
some would say that they've been the
most effective opposition for 12 years
at the last conservative government
the laws of course and I and there's
very good people in the House of Lords
but we need to bring it into the 21st
century it needs to be a modern second
chamber and therefore it should be
elected and I think when trusting
politics is so low because of the
actions of Boris Johnson and he's
actually trying to make appointments to
the House of Lords which people feel or
have felt is inappropriate I think the
time is right to democratize the House
of Lords but this is part of a a
commission that will soon a
recommendation from a commission that
will soon be published and all these
matters will have a proper consultation
on how democracy in the House of Lords
what how it could be implemented uh how
the regional voice is can be part of
that and so on
okay and now finally uh the World Cup of
course kicks off uh today and there's
been lots of criticism of Qatar is it
right for us to continue to talk about
this or do you think now perhaps is the
time to focus on uh the sport
well you know
actually in England uh of course of
course I will and supporting England
obviously
I think we should continue talking about
the issues because a qatar's human
rights record particularly around like
how they treat LGBT people but also the
way in which the workers who have been
building stadiums have lost their lives
and been abused it's quite right that
the world focuses on that as well and
puts pressure on the Qatari government
while at the same time enjoying football
so look I'm going to be watching England
but I think we have to continue to talk
about this very these awful abuses that
we see in Qatar okay thank you very much
indeed Jonathan Ashworth there thank you